recording in progress and we'll take
your questions
for the professors if you put those into
the Q a function in Zoom that will um
help us find those questions when we get
to the Q a so that's the best place to
place them and if you are watching on
YouTube live you can put them into the
chat box
so let's begin
and um
one moment
sorry
yeah
so let's talk about the
role of digital marketing in the digital
economy
Professor
let the slide come okay it's coming yeah
here we go
uh thanks to Art so and welcome
everybody to this webinar
so uh basically all of us know that the
economy overall is moving towards
digital transformation and we are using
digital for every aspect of sales and
marketing so like either we customer
acquisition creating brand awareness
understanding what the customer want
even the relationship management
and it you see more and more the
traditional media like the newspapers TV
are getting replaced by social media and
even the buyer or consumers
they prefer
or give much more importance to
electronic water mouth compared to what
the brands want to communicate through
their advertisement or traditional
advertisement so if you want to buy any
restaurant or want to buy a go to any
Resort or buy any expensive Electronics
the first thing we do is to basically go
to and view the reviews in different
places so that is also excellent source
of information about understanding what
the customer wants from the brand and as
a result more and more organizers are
becoming digital and if you see like
even in India most of the retail stores
like who are traditional brick and
mortar they are nowadays now not so much
successful is the era Omni Channel
retailing the retail store which has
both online and offline they are more
successful so
with this we will speak about it much
more in the details when we join these
basically program so now we'll hand over
to for the next slide
okay and it's like Professor sivaji to
um
talk about this in the slide after
yeah uh thanks Stuart uh I welcome
everybody I hope my voice is clear and
uh it's loud and clear to everybody so
uh let's talk about the different career
options that you have as a digital
Market when you acquire a digital
marketing skills first of all let me
tell you this digital marketing world is
very Dynamic okay so you need to keep
upgrading yourself you need to keep
learning okay and these learnings are
majorly many a times by trial and error
also okay so let's talk about a digital
marketer this is the uh job aspect of a
digital marketing manager okay so
digital marketing manager as a whole
talks about and takes care of the
digital well-being how the company is
performing digitally you know what are
the contents it's performing how it's
doing its social media's campaign
strategies and everything is the overall
digit uh job of the digital marketing
manager to keep a track of everything of
each part of the digital aspect okay now
one by one you will be having you can
also be an email marketing manager or a
specialist in the email marketing many
times you might have seen you know there
are certain emails that reach out to you
uh for feedback emails reach out to you
for you know coupons or which we call a
sales promotional activities and many
times we ended end up buying or opening
emails and even clicking uh from the
emails and end up into the product page
so how are these emails being triggered
you know what makes you uh uh what makes
the conversion happens which uh keywords
actually are working so that keeps them
and that's the work of a email marketing
manager content marketing manager as you
know it's the era of 2023 so we talk
about content is the king so everything
you do digitally if you're
okay
it is not up to the date uh nobody will
be you know uh like to until and unless
your content is up to the date providing
the information that uses a search where
uh your content uh you know uh your uh
products will not be selling you would
be not at the top of the mind of the
consumers that is one of the major
objectives right so content marketing
manager is uh responsible for say the
content being created be it Instagram uh
be the link post implemented by the
company the emails that have been
created okay that are being you know
circulated or broadcasted you can say so
all the different types of Beats and
YouTube video that is uh uh you know
YouTube video ad that is being created
for conversion so all these are a part
of content marketing manager or the blog
posts the normal blog post or even the
uh the content of the website these are
all part of the content marketing
manager now talk about the social Med
social media strategist okay many a days
these days companies are adopting or you
know uh you can say companies are
providing a special role as a social
media uh strategist or social media
manager to you so these uh actually you
know these uh uh social media the
objective of social media manager is to
keep a track of you know uh all the
happenings of the social media social
media is quite uh you know trending and
it's quite dynamic in nature so today uh
one thing which is which went viral
tomorrow it's not viral right so the
virality of the content is very much
crucial so it should reach out to the
right person at the right point of time
when the person is searching for or the
person has an intent towards the product
or the services right so social media
manager has to take keep a track of
where are the customers where are the
customers searching for what kind of
content they are consuming how to
strategize that these are all part of
the social media manager now talk about
the digital advertising manager so uh
you would be hearing about or you would
be seeing these days you must have
observed you know there are multiple ads
coming on YouTube uh at least two ads
even before a video starts so how are
these ads being created there is an
option within the ad that drives you
towards you know uh the web page or the
product page so how are these being done
so these are all examples of digital
advertising manager pay-per-click
marketing planner so many times you are
also you know clicking or searching for
the ad and you're paying for the ad
right so
um sorry you are not paying so when many
times you're clicking for the ad and uh
the website that you land up is paying
to Google or the search engine
um that it is operating with so many
times uh that's how is the budget being
uh you know uh
we can talk about the objective of a
pay-per-click marketing management
planner is to how is to allocate the
budget along different search engine
platforms how it is working which
keywords to Target uh where are the
customers searching for what are the
keywords customers are searching for all
these are the part of pay-per-click
marketing planner e-commerce manager
manages how the e-commerce websites are
looking for how is you know the
visibility of the products how is the
you know accessibility of different uh
products available to the e-commerce
platform all these are taken care of by
e-commerce manager whereas website
managers also takes care of the certain
aspects uh like how is the website
looking what are the you know title tags
meta tags how are they working how are
they functioning and they have to be
kept on changing right it's not that
once you are done and done so that's
that has to be you know very dynamic in
nature so website manager takes the
takes care of the you know overall flow
of the website how it is you know the
website should run as fast as possible
should not take much of the time time so
the loading time all these are taken
into consideration by the website
manager and lastly the SEO analyst so uh
many these days almost majority of the
companies recruit an SEO Specialist or a
SEO analyst who make sure that the
website ranks higher for the you know uh
for the keyword or for the product or
the services that the company is
offering so that's that is an example
that is a duty of the SEO analyst to
make sure that the website runs higher
and higher so everybody you you might
have remembered you know uh nobody
remembers the web uh the person who
comes second so it's always the you know
the websites are on a race you know to
become the first and you have experience
that you know you generally visit the
first page of uh the search engine
result page right you then you are
rarely looking for uh or clicking on the
second page so definitely it's an
objective of the website to rank Higher
and Higher and that's taken care by the
SEO analysts okay moving on next uh can
we have the next slide please yeah
so these are some of the skills uh you
know that need to be kept it up uh kept
uh that you need to learn and you need
to keep yourself updated with for
example SEO optimization so what does an
SEO specialist does is he optimizes the
search engine results accordingly he
makes certain changes there are certain
you know tricks and techniques that has
to be incorporated in your website so
that your website ranks higher and
higher in for a particular keyword okay
so for a particular keyword or for a
particular product on the services which
the company is meant for uh content
marketing so definitely how are you
creating content okay how are you
managing the content how are you know
what is the strategy behind it which
kind of content people like what are the
keywords what are the hashtags you're
using for that all these has to be taken
care of web analytics okay
now nothing you cannot understand uh
until and unless it is Data driven okay
your decision has to be made based on
certain data right so data based
decision making is takes you for a
longer run right so definitely web
analytics helps you in understanding how
are your consumers performing right so
what are the which kind of consumers are
visiting your website which kind of
customers are bouncing back from your
website which kind of customers are
visiting your social media web page so
all these are taken into consideration
into web analytics and how can we target
them so these are all a part of your web
analytics website management and
optimization you can talk about you know
uh different ways in order to optimize
the website right so as soon it is it is
it is you know it is a general rule of
thumb that the website should load
within two seconds okay now we do not uh
you can say we do not uh like to wait
right uh SO waiting time is uh very much
uh boring to everyone body of us right
so website management and optimization
is one of the key aspects of that you
know so how how can we make the codes
and how can you know uh the website be
managed in such a way uh that it it
loads faster and faster and also it
matches to the uh you know uh to the uh
say the um information that the users
are searching for so that has to be
taken care of as a part of website
manager and optimization social media
strategies so what kind of when where
how to post has is a part of social
media strategy so uh there are certain
platforms that are being created you
know uh certain calendars social media
posting calendars that are being created
which takes into consideration of how
the website uh how the social media
social media posts are going live
um
I can't see the screen is there yeah
okay now let's talk about the email
marketing yeah so email marketing talks
about you know uh how what are the kinds
of emails that are uh being uh
broadcasted to its customers right so
for example whenever you uh register for
a company buy an app or whatever there
is a different kind of email that
reaches to you whenever you left left
your product into the cart and did not
check out a different kind of email
comes to you uh whenever you bought a
product and you uh there then a review
email comes to you so there are
different kinds of email that are being
uh you know curated for different kind
of situation and how these contents are
being created these are all parts of
email marketing strategy a pay-per-click
strategy so how much uh to spend
in order to you know uh uh so how much
to spend in order to uh uh so for
example suppose pay-per-click strategy
is uh what is the strategy to be adopted
in terms of uh of the this uh say the
digital ads or the surcharge that are
coming into the picture Okay so that is
an uh part of pay-per-click uh strategy
ad testing which kind of ads people are
clicking which kind of extensions are
working so these are all part of AD
expense II ad testing and extensions
keyword organization and match types
different kinds of keywords multiple
websites are using multiple keywords
okay so how can you optimize your
business or your website according to
the keywords campaign and AD group
organization so how can you manage
different ads okay so one company would
be running multiple ads at a certain
period of time or multiple campaign so
how can you manage all that uh say via
using Google ads uh for example is is a
part of campaign and AD group
organization so I hope uh I'm able to
you know uh provide you a glimpse of
what a digital marketing roles and what
are the you know uh key skills that you
will be learning however there's a there
were a lot more we'll be discussing on
the floor over to you steward
thank you very much professor and at
this point I'm going to ask you the
first of uh several questions for the
audience
um
so
you're all here because you're
interested in digital marketing as a
career field but so why have you not
taken a certification course of this
type up till date
there are several reasons you might have
so you pick
any one two three or all four of them
let us know
you're watching on the streaming service
please uh put that in your chat box
and we'll let this run for about another
10 seconds get your answers in please
yeah
I'll close the poll in
three seconds
and here's what you told us
so the
biggest objection people have is not
finding a course that has a fully
comprehensive curriculum that covers all
of the roles and skills that the
professors just described
and then the next uh biggest objections
are not feeling you would have practical
experience that you could use to
demonstrate your new skills to uh an
employer
and not finding time in your work
schedule for the study so
let's
address those
and
talk about how this program the digital
marketing program
from IMT ghaziabad
addresses each of those objections it is
a fully comprehensive curriculum as we
will discuss shortly it's an
industry-aligned learning path
uh the The Institute has developed
from its long experience in working with
companies in industry and knowing their
requirements for what they're looking
for in new hires
is based on learning by doing integrated
case studies and Hands-On projects that
give you practical experience
that builds up a portfolio that you can
take with you from the program to show
off to employers your new set of skills
how you've solved digital marketing
problems real examples
uh the program is delivered fully online
and much of the the learning is through
online live virtual classes
where you're not just looking at videos
but you're interacting live with your
instructors going through examples with
them able to ask them questions respond
to the questions they ask you able to
interact with your classmates in the
environment but it's all done online
from the comfort of your desk or your
home
on your laptop or on your desktop device
you can even study much of the
study materials from a mobile device if
you choose it's all available any
platform or device that you want to use
and it's available 24 7. so other than
the fixed class times for the live
classes
you can do your work at any time that's
convenient for you
um
and we are in partnership with meta
first some of the material here so you
have even greater experience and
exposure to Industry experts
and the program duration is five months
with the commitment of about 10 hours a
week of time so almost everyone working
environment you can find that 10 hour
carve out time so
we feel that this is flexible enough to
meet the lifestyle and schedule for
almost everyone
at the end of the process after the five
months you will have learned earned your
certificate your professional
certificate from The Institute and
it certifies that you have completed all
the core courses
satisfactorily that you've completed
your final project that
Institute has confidence that you have
the skills of a digital marketer you'll
have done the cans on case study
projects you'll have done the final
Capstone project which we'll talk about
a bit more
a few moments
along the way you can take master
classes with industry leaders as an
elective you can take
master classes from The Institute
faculty as an elective and
you will have earned
not only associate alumni status from
The Institute but you also receive an
exam voucher that allows you to get a
meta certificate
separate certification process from meta
so all of these are part of the program
and what you get out of it
um I'd like Professor Sandeep if if you
would to speak about
IMT ghaziabad
okay yeah uh good evening everyone uh
welcome to this webinar uh so it's about
IMT is a very early shoot around more
than 40 years old Institute and we are
among the top Institute in India
we have many accolades with us like we
have a system accreditation this is
international accreditation and also a
part of it we also have a national
accreditation also
and I I think and we and we have I think
uh more than thousand uh alumni who are
working in the top positions in India
and abroad and also our marketing
program is a flagship program and we
have a faculty more than uh uh uh I
think I think more than 10 faculty in a
marketing area around I think 15 and
also most of the faculty cover very
strong experience uh of Academia plus
also from industry and really I'm very
proud to be the part of this institute
and and and uh I think all of you will
enjoy being a part of this digital
marketing program where our faculty will
deliver the uh the content of this
program and also uh will be a very good
Mentor for you uh in your uh career
Journey or so so this is all about IMT
if you have some more questions then
we'll take up in the uh in the question
answer sessions thank you thank you yeah
thank you Professor Bindu
um I'd also like to point out as we
mentioned the meta connection
um
one of the the things that we helped uh
bring to the table as simply learned is
uh our association with meta
um so we were able to facilitate adding
that to the program and that allows you
to take some of the classes from
meta instructors
ask me anything sessions Master sessions
um and as I mentioned you'll be able to
earn the
blueprint certification with the exam
prep and the voucher that we provide in
this program so it's an additional bonus
and a benefit from being part of this
program
excuse me
um to be eligible for the program this
is a
postgraduate program so that you do have
to have a bachelor's degree which may be
in any discipline
and you do have to have a minimum of two
years of work experience formal work
experience in any field
um it is desirable that you have some
exposure to digital marketing but that's
not required because the program is
designed
to take you uh
to expertise in digital marketing
whether you have that background coming
in or not
so these are the things you must have
and I'm going to ask the audience
another poll question regarding your
current level of experience
and how much experience you have in
formal work
again not necessarily in digital
marketing
let's go for another
five seconds
I'll close the poll
now
so while we have a sizable number of
people who are still in school
um
there's about a third of our audience
that fall into the three or more years
of experience level
and so if you're uh on the cusp in terms
of the amount of experience you have
um
please contact us and we'll we'll
evaluate that but also if you're
currently studying you'll probably want
to keep this program in mind for when
you have your bachelor's degree
awarded
and
sorry I forgot to share the results here
you can see that
let me move on
but we'll speak about how this program
prepares you
Professor superjute if you would uh tell
us about the curriculum
yeah thank you Stuart yeah so uh how is
this program being designed okay so
first of all you will be having a
program introduction induction sessions
okay uh you will be talking about you
will be taken through how what what is
the uh what is the uh you know the key
requirements of the program what are the
assignments you will be given what are
the projects that you have to do so all
these are taken is the program intro
induction now talking about there will
be sessions by you know a faculty mentor
on in in the introduction to digital
marketing we'll be talking and
introducing you to the world of digital
marketing how digital marketing Works
different aspects of digital marketing
uh how data-driven decision making will
be helpful uh in this aspect so all
these are taken into consideration as
the induction of the uh introduction of
digital to digital marketing next we
have is the SEO which is the search
engine optimization in the search engine
optimization we will be showing you
certain tricks and techniques and there
will be Hands-On sessions you know in
order to help you with you know how how
what strategies to be you know developed
as a SEO specialist which can help you
in ranking higher in your search engine
results page for by far is the since
Google is one of the you know uh search
engine results uh search engines which
is capturing almost around 90 of the
market share so we'll be majorly talking
about how to rank higher in the Google
search engine result page now the next
session the next module will have about
pay-per-click in pay-per-click we'll be
talking about and introducing you to the
different uh to the different kinds of
uh display ads as well as search ads and
how they work okay now we'll be also
talking about we'll be having a Hands-On
session on these also how to develop an
ad uh how to develop you know how to
create your own Google ads uh we'll be
taking you through step by step step
okay how to create Google ads and uh
date a search ad to display ad and what
tricks and techniques should be taken
into consideration by designing your ad
okay so there are different uh kinds of
you know you can say talk about
different uh there could be you can
segregate the customers based on the
location you can segregate the customers
based on their preferences you can
segregate the customers based on their
you know uh you can go deeper and deeper
in creating your own Niche segment of
customers okay so how pay-per-click can
be you know so that you can optimize
your budget and you not spend all over
the place so that you know
um as soon as uh in pay-per-click
whenever a customer clicks on the ad be
it a display ad or a search ad the uh
the you can say the pub uh The
Advertiser has to pay to the publisher
who is publishing the ad right so in
this aspect it's the Google or if it is
the other websites which are like the
news forums you see which have lots of
ads over there all over the place so
whenever you click you are you know the
advertiser has to pay to the publisher
in that aspect we'll be talking about
taking you through the different kinds
of pay-per-click ads and uh we'll be
also taking your Hands-On session of how
to create Google ads uh the next module
will be talking about social media
marketing so we'll be talking about the
different platforms of social media
marketing we'll be focusing on how
content is being created in social media
marketing we'll be having a Hands-On
session with you know Facebook meta a
metaphor businesses we'll be taking uh
how uh Facebook ads are working how to
create Facebook ads LinkedIn ads will be
talking about all these then we have web
analytics web analytics will be talking
about you know the data so how was how
the data from the websites are being
utilized how to clean that data how to
utilize that data towards making
different decisions okay uh business
decisions then we'll be talking about
marketing analytics so marketing
analytics to see the overall holistic
picture in terms of your you know
digital marketing so are the data is the
data or is the data saying you the thing
that you wanted to hear right is uh the
data helping you in your decision making
and finally we'll be having a Capstone
project a digital marketing Capstone
project which will be incorporating all
of these uh key skills that you have
learned in different modules and you'll
be delivering a project okay so we'll be
talking about that it's it's a holistic
approach it's a one Capstone project
that we'll be taking into consideration
all your skills that you have learned
and you have to deliver a project okay
so we'll be talking about the Capstone
project in the uh in in the upcoming
slides as well in details okay
yeah over to you store
right thank you professor and uh as as
you can see along the right hand side
there's also the electives
um the electives are uh yours to access
without any additional cost they're
based on your level of interest in each
of those topics and your commitment to
the time to learn them and you can take
any one or all of them uh these include
the master sessions as I mentioned from
meta and from other digital leaders that
will be brought in but they also
include some of the topics brand
management mobile marketing email
marketing content marketing
conversion rate optimization well any of
those might want to specialize in you
can take those electives at your
discretion so that's a great aspect of
the program
um
and the program requires you to use a
number of different tools so this is a
sampling of the tools that you'll be
using in your projects in your case
studies and at the end of the program
you will be able to show
concrete examples of how you've used
these tools so that you can say not just
that you're familiar with them or you
know the names of them or the purposes
of them but you can show examples of how
you've employed them in your work and
demonstrate that you have these as part
of your skill set
the
and many more than just these but these
are this is a sampling
um
and the Capstone project which we've
mentioned many times is the last module
of the program it's about a three to
four week course
and it is done under the mentorship of
one of your instructors meet with them
weekly to review your progress but what
you'll do is you'll pick a program a
problem in them later on we'll we'll
show you some of the choices for that
um and the problem will be stated as an
industry relevant
problems that a company needs to solve
in digital marketing and you'll pick the
one that you find most interesting and
you'll work on it for several weeks to
Create Your solution using all of the
skills and tools that you've learned
along the way in the program
when you turn in that project it's
graded for your
final exam so to speak and it becomes uh
Criterion for being awarded the
certificate but it's also something
that's in your portfolio that you take
with you on a permanent basis to show
off to Future employers
so it is a very valuable part of this
program
and
just describe to you the learning
environment one of the things about the
learning environment is that it is fully
digital it is fully integrated it allows
you to see your
full uh curriculum in advance and see
all the classes you need to complete and
all the electives you have available it
gives you a class schedule for your live
classroom
sessions
allows you to do your tests and
assessments and your projects and it
gives you tracking of which courses
you've completed
the certificate you get awarded for each
course and then the final certificate
once you've completed all of the core
courses successfully in your Capstone
project you're able to unlock your final
certificate for the program
along the way it provides you support
tools including a community feature
which allows you to interact with your
fellow Learners with your instructors
with other instructors a 24x7 support
desk from Simply learn which allows you
to get support both on the operation of
the platform but also on the subject
matter so that if you happen to be
working at three o'clock in the morning
on a project and reach a doubt or a
blocker you'll be able to reach out to
somebody and get help with that
the
program leaders that you have here today
in the session
Professor Sunday Professor Bindu and
Professor subijit uh
are all senior
faculty and program directors at the
Institute and uh
might ask each of them to to give a
short introduction of themselves
starting with Professor Sandeep
hi thanks to Art again so I am with
working with IMT for last five years
prior to that I have worked almost 20
years in the industry so uh in different
sales marketing and pre-sales role so
like in terms of my academic I have done
my engineering then MBA from IIM
Calcutta and PhD from MDI gurgaon and I
primarily teach and research on areas
related to analytic like marketing
analytics social media analytics and B2B
sales and marketing and I also have a
book that is published that talks about
the sales and marketing in the IIT
industry now I will hand over to
Professor Bindu
foreign
so I'm not teaching in this program but
I am the program director of this
program
I have done my PhD Psychology from IIT
kanpur uh with my I am with IMT I am
working with the last 20 years and my
most of the teaching areas are in the in
my domain expertise like cognition
Behavior performance management
cross-culture management and I do
research around the sales employee
that's that's maybe one of the interest
in this program and also I do want some
leadership uh uh and uh and also the
creativity some of the my research
domain are there okay and thanks all of
you to be here uh I head over to budget
please introduce yourself thank you
thank you everyone
thank you Professor uh good evening
everyone I am Professor shibuji so I
recently joined IMT however I have been
uh teaching uh the courses of digital
marketing at IMT itself and before
joining IMT I was working at Japanese I
was teaching digital marketing there as
well
um I am uh I hold a PhD in marketing
from IIT kharagpur West Bengal India
um and uh it's it's one of my favorite
subjects to teach because it's very you
know dynamic in nature connects with the
you know upcoming Trends so I really
enjoy it so thank you everyone
or what you used to it thank you so much
professors I appreciate your sharing
your backgrounds with us
um we'll talk about learner outcomes and
here are a couple of individuals
uh who have taken the program and gotten
great results from it Aaron um
mentions that he received a salary hike
of 40 percent based on his abilities and
new skills that he gained in the program
um and uh RG
uh is working uh
pressure level within the industry
um but he's
very pleased with the the
nature of the instruction and the skills
he's gained so
um we expect that if you
take this program you will have similar
stories to tell
um one of the reasons we believe that is
because part of this program that
extends it for six months after you
earned your certificate
is to Simply learned job assist program
um
I'm going to ask if I'm a Chandra would
like to speak about this or would you
prefer that I do that
you can go ahead to it all right very
good um so the simply learned career
service is for Learners in India uh
offers three aspects one is provided by
simply learning on an ongoing basis
which is expert webinars and career
events that we do online weekly
able to access for free forever
um you have the real world projects up
to and including the Capstone project in
your portfolio that you leave the
program with and the third part is the
formal job assist services from IIM jobs
which complete
for six months after the
program so you can access the job portal
which has an exclusive job listings
and a
discrete and confidential
application process
we think that is very valuable but I my
opinion the other aspects are more
valuable the resume rewrite service is
valuable because in today's environment
the first place your resume goes is into
an automated tracking system where it's
evaluated by an AI bot that matches it
against
job descriptions
the ability for your resume to be read
by and understood by the bot is
important aspect of resume writing is
not necessarily something that comes
naturally to people so having
professional help with that is important
and then recognizing that once it passes
that filter
your resume will go into
um onto somebody's desktop or screen
so it still needs to be attractive to
the human eye and
balancing those two objectives between
the AI bot compatibility and
attractiveness to a human interviewer
those two things are essentially an art
form and having a professional help with
that is extremely valuable to you
similarly the one-on-one interview
service prepares you for the very
types of interviews that you'll face
from the phone screen from an HR person
to uh initial skills interviews that uh
for your the people who will be managing
your work directly to the cultural fit
and management fit in interviews that
you'll have with more senior members of
your hiring so you need to be prepared
to go through those different rounds of
interviews each requiring slightly
different skills and having this
one-on-one preparation is really
valuable part of this service so all of
these are available to you to help you
in your job search this is not a job
guarantee program by any means but it is
extremely valuable set of services that
will help you find your job Focus your
job search
I mentioned the expert webinars which
cover many different topics both
Technical and career-based
and these are generally one hour
sessions that you can attend online as
you're doing today
that will give you overviews on
different aspects of industry or advice
on how to
mold your career and build your skill
set and run your job search so all of
these are available to you
and then we talk about the case studies
so in this program you've got a number
of different
case studies based on the Harvard
Business School case studies uh in
different Industries taken directly from
Real World Companies like dominoes or
Volkswagen
um give India
um
so all of these are projects that you
will work on and and
look at the problems these companies
face and come up with your approach to
each solution
then we talk about the Capstone project
in which case
you will pick one of these four domains
travel banking Financial consumer goods
or hospitality and you'll take on the
challenge of
creating a campaign to drive customer
engagement using social media and other
digital marketing tools build that
project that will be evaluated by your
instructor for your final exam in the
course
well the next cohort starts the classes
start on 11 March
um
and the cost of this program is one Lock
17 700.
which can be financed at zero cost
financing at 3907 rupee a month
um as I mentioned at the outset of the
session there is a bonus for you for
attending this evening that bonus is a
15 discount so if you sign up from this
program from this webinar for the
program uh you can receive a 15 discount
off of that program fee
um
so you'd want to contact us and ask us
at simplylearn.net for that
and in fact we'll ask you now
based on what you've heard so far from
the professors from Chandra myself
um
are you
interested in taking this program
not a commitment but just a level of
Interest
I'll let this run for about 15 seconds
since it's a yes or no question
and here we go
close five four three
two one
all right
and more than three quarters of our
audience are interested in taking the
program which is fantastic very pleased
for that and then I will show you
the steps
for enrollment very straightforward you
will email us at ask us to
simplylearn.net and if you bear with me
for a moment I will put that email
address
into the chat so it's at your fingertips
and
once you do our learning Consultants
will ask you certain questions about
your
additional background because you do
have to have a
bachelor's degree they'll ask you to
prove your work history to show that you
have the minimum of two years work
requirements and you'll be assessed your
uh
aptitude and your interest in digital
marketing you want to make
second I'll be with you in a moment
Zoom is
okay
my apologies for that uh
did have a small Zoom crash on my end
but I will get this restarted in just a
second first I'm going to put the uh
information into the chat for everyone
about the
program page as well as the
email address
that's in the chat for you
and then I will go back to the
presentation here
apologize for that uh brief interruption
so again
um we'll work with you to review your
application and send you the admission
letter so once you receive the admission
letter you can choose to pay the fees
either all at once or on a
Finance program
if you're interested if you're among the
75 percent who said you're interested
how soon would you
want to start the program
again I'll leave this open for just a
brief period it's a simple question so
about another 10 seconds
and I'll close in five four three
two one
so it looks like about 60 percent of our
audience would like to start either in
the March cohort or the ones afterward
in April May
and that's fantastic if you're looking
to do this further out
um
for example if you're if you're not
quite there in terms of your degree or
your work experience please contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net and we'll
go over what additional requirements you
you may need to fulfill and keep you in
touch for future uh batches of this
program so
always good to reach out to us at this
point I'm going to go to questions and
answers with the professors
stop sharing the screens so you don't
stare at the slide
we'll move into
questions themselves so I want to see if
we have any coming in I don't see any
from our social team so
we'll go into the Q a
here hold on one moment I'm just moving
the window so I can see it better
there we go got it
uh first question will we be issued a
certificate after this training
so if you answer yes to the next
question the next poll question we'll be
able to send you a proof of attendance
for this session
um which does only signifies that you
we're here uh
would you classify
the uh professor
any one of you professors can take this
question the question is from
uh
hello to
um yes would you clarify the basic
distinction between e-commerce
and digital marketing websites
so I can go ahead with this question so
uh in terms of e-commerce and gender
websites you will be seeing so how does
digital marketing differs for them is
for example suppose uh e-commerce
platforms are multiple platforms like
let's talk about Flipkart Amazon uh say
uh Mantra these are various e-commerce
platform where there's a transaction
happening okay however in terms of
websites it could be a blog post website
okay it could be a forum it could be
news article newspaper website okay
where are different digital marketing
this different display ads are being
there as well okay so those all fall
into the figure of uh you know display
ads where you talk about the
pay-per-click ads or PPC which we talked
about in uh previously so these are part
of the website however e-commerce bears
are specifically towards selling of the
product however but
websites are not specifically towards
selling of the product but will take you
to a website which sells the product or
or any other services or a subscription
to their websites or some some other
form of you know in interaction or
engagement
so I hope I'm able to answer this
question perfect
um
we have a question uh maybe hamachandra
can answer as well uh what is the type
of salary package of fresher and digital
marketing might earn
see something around uh you know 30 to
50 000 rupees I would say
on our monthly basis is that yes
yeah and then the the
upper limit of that is much higher as
you as you gain more experience you can
move up in the scale so so I'm talking
about pressure yeah
um
just a question for the professors
people say that AI will kill digital
marketing and all the
talk about chat GPT uh putting content
creators out of business
you say something about that and how
that how that will affect the digital
marketing space
okay maybe I would first respond then
Professor surajit can join so uh if you
see that the question can be broken into
three part which is like immediate and
Midterm and long term in the immediate
also you know the digital marketing is
quite like a tool driven and we have
algorithm and other compared to the
traditional marketing so that part is
already taken care and people are aware
of that AI can do many things but we
need more and more people to actually
create a very good business case out of
that Implement that
then bring uh so value for that but in
the long term or in the medium term
there is a chance that many of the
traditional uh the work where you need
less or the work which are repetitive
will go to the AI like uh we are already
seeing lots of work in the text analytic
area uh which like uh understanding the
sentiment of the text or all those
things which are taken over by the
I'll go
we're getting an intermediate breakup of
your voice uh Professor you're freezing
a little bit
done manually so far but we also need
people who basically understand the
technology and can create use case for
them and also uh basically customize
specifically for particular
organizations so uh like some of the
jobs we'll go but more and more new jobs
will also come into the picture so there
is no great reduction of job would
happen but there will be changes in the
type of job that comes so uh so there is
a need to a little bit upskill ourselves
so that's the thing so Professor you
want to add something
wow to me if you personally ask I would
say you know AI would facilitate the
process definitely uh and it will make
it much more easier but uh the uh you
know the basic decision making skills or
you know how a business works or what
works actually in a business so this has
to be you know this has to be taken by
humans so that can never be you know uh
uh ignored I would say
okay
um
did you want to mention something from
the operation side Professor Bindu
um regarding what regarding the effect
of AI
I think uh what the professors have
answered very well so I think I have
nothing to add to that all right thank
you we have a question from an attendee
who is a computer science teacher has
been for 20 years and is curious to know
whether this will help you know trans uh
translate into a different career
digital marketing
um what can what kind of insights would
you offer him
uh uh the thing is what kind of uh is he
uh the question to him would be is he uh
opting for a change of his profession is
he looking for since he is a computer
science teacher is he looking for a
change of his career plans so that would
be a question in that aspect it will be
if it would be you know uh we can answer
that in you know you can opt but it will
be again a freshest job and again you
have to go through the you know uh the
digital marketing jobs that are
available in the market however if you
are a part of this uh you know uh module
and if you learn about digital marketing
definitely you know I think irrespective
of anybody uh all everybody requires
digital certain knowledge of digital
marketing B it talk about let's talk
about LinkedIn okay what is LinkedIn
about it's creating your own personal
brand okay so if even if you're not
doing for a company you have to create
your own brand so it's it's a part of a
personal branding technique so I think
uh it can enhance anybody's skills today
in this digital era so understanding
that could be a much more you know uh
would provide you a better understanding
towards the digital world I would say
I think also uh like he is a computer
teacher if he wants to be a trainer or
want to teach student on digital
marketing so that can be another natural
extension for him because there are lots
of requirement in the nowadays in the
colleges and others that student want to
know about digital marketing and so
because he already has the programming
background in others so he would be able
to quickly take this and add his
teaching portfolio or enhance the
teaching portfolio Maybe
thank you
um we had somebody ask if there's an age
criteria for this program
and certainly there is
no age criteria but I think graduates in
this uh good yeah
um thank you and
can uh sarab asks is Performance
Marketing different from digital
marketing
Professor subichi could you address that
difference between Performance Marketing
and digital marketing how they interact
so uh in terms of Performance Marketing
it's uh so where does digital uh
marketing works is digital marketing
talks about how we are performing how
your business is performing digitally
right however uh in terms of uh the
offline sales that happens okay many a
times which are taken into consideration
which would be an influence of the
digital marketing and in the longer run
the person buys your products the
services and uh is and the sale goes up
however Performance Marketing takes care
of all those things however digital
marketing takes care of how can a
digital campaign or how specifically you
know your digital
um you can say properties of the website
or be it a website be it your social
media handles or be it your you know uh
ads that you are advertising that you're
doing so it takes about your digital
properties into consideration enhance
your business
thank you we're getting to the end of
our hour so I'll take one last question
an attendee asked about the financing
options for the program and
affordability so please contact us and
ask us at simplylearn.net they'll be
able to answer your questions about the
payment plan about any other about the
discount offer and then the other
programs that we have to assist you with
that so with that I'm going to move on
to the last part of our our webinar
and
and addressing
question and the purple over
attendees
so do you need us assistance with
enrollment and if you are interested in
receiving
just a proof of attendance for today's
session
um
answer yes to this we'll send you a
proof of attendance certificate for this
for this session
um again that doesn't certify the
you're a digital marketer certifies you
came to the sessions
and I'll leave this open for another
three
two
one
all right
so about eighty percent of our audience
respondents said that they are
interested so uh we'll reach out to you
with that information
and with that I would like to thank
Professor Bindu Professor Sandeep and
Professor Mr majeed for being here this
evening and sharing so generously with
their time and their knowledge
and
thank you professors
thank you Stuart thank you very much
team for organizing this
thank you everyone
thank you how much render for uh
assisting and I want to thank everyone
who attended this evening uh all of you
in the audience for being here
and uh we would love to invite you to
join the int ghaziabad learning team
learning community
along with us and simply learn
and
that concludes our webinar for the
evening
we hope that you'll reach out to us at
ask us at simplylearn.net
QR code to go to the web page
with that
concludes our webinar thank you very
much thank you thank you